hey what's going on i'm red mufflerman
if you've been chilling around gce for
the last few weeks you've probably
already seen a few of the things i've
posted on the channel already but over
the last few weeks it kind of just
dawned on me that
i'd never actually introduced myself i
kind of just started posting content
overnight and just
never stopped it was like the youtuber
equivalent of showing up to a party
unannounced but i brought a veggie tray
and so people just kind of let me in but
uh
hey everyone i'm red muffler man or you
might also know me as gordon the
previous editor over at comics explained
i like anime and manga a lot i play a
lot of fighting games like guilty gear
and melty blood i think spider-verse is
the best thing that marvel has ever
touched i'm a streamer a voice actor a
content creator and
yeah i just like to make cool i've been
working with rob for a real long time at
this point and the story about how i
actually met rob is kind of funny uh i
was looking for editing jobs at one
point after being unemployed for like
nine months and i just see this ad for
comics explained on craigslist of all
places and he's just like hey man i'm
like uh i'm looking for an editor and he
had the colossus explain video popped up
and i'm just like i guess i could do
this so i apply i get a skype interview
like 20 minutes later next thing i know
he sends me a test i send it back he's
like okay this is good work he sends me
a check and i immediately almost fall to
my knees and cry and from there i've
kind of just tumbled and fumbled my way
and next thing i know i'm the head of
creative over here at geek culture
explained life's wild you know
but yeah over the last few months i've
been working with rob to kind of make
his job making videos just a little bit
easier
and also
i've been working on my own series for
the channel it's a series called comics
explained badly or simply just explained
badly my goal is to essentially go over
the history of a character in a quick
and comedic way i've always liked to
have a fast-paced comedic edge to the
stories i tell and i like to be able to
poke fun at the things that i love
while also telling you why i love them
and that's where this series came to be
it'll be a bi-weekly series airing every
other sunday and the first episode will
be spider-man explained badly airing
this sunday september 4th and honestly i
hope you like it this is something i've
been wanting to make for a very long
time and the fact that rob and everyone
has been
incredibly supportive of me with making
this i'm so excited to put these out i
have been having so much fun in the
writer's room just sitting down either
by myself or with my co-editor jacob
and us just kind of sitting down and
getting to be able to like workshop some
stuff together
and
oh my god i i legitimately love what i'm
doing with this
and
i hope that you all love it too honestly
but feel free to drop your thoughts in a
comment below and i hope you check
everything out this sunday september 4th
and as for the editorials i've been
doing i'll have a little more to say i
think once we get a little closer to
october
because there's a lot of good anime
coming out in october oh my god have you
seen chainsaw man god damn
but yeah that's it for me if you like
what we do feel free to drop a like
subscribe and leave a comment below and
if you like me you can find my twitch
twitter and youtube at red muffler mad
and uh yeah
have a good one everybody
take it easy